dortmund empfängt wolfsburg der bvb mit
personalsorgen marco rose setzte es aber
auf die jugend und bringt von rothe in
der startformation
dem 17-jährigen gelingt ein
traumeinstand bei seinem debüt ecke
brand kopfball rote 10 dortmund 24
minute rote mit 17 jahren und 169 tagen
der viertjüngste torschütze der
bundesliga geschichte
nur zwei minuten später blitze nach
toller vorarbeit zum 2 0 dortmund
gelingt an diesem spieltag fast alles
wolfsburg fast nichts wieder zwei
minuten später freistoß reusser kann sie
zum 13 0
wolfsburg oft einfach zu passiv der bvb
bei sky thenried 14 0 für die borussia
einer der im schwarz-gelben zu erreichen
natürlich nicht fehlen darf erling
holland zum 50 der norweger beendet eine
fünf spiele tore flaute dortmund
innerhalb von 14 minuten mit fünf
treffern kurve zwölf erleben ein debakel
nach dem seitenwechsel schnürt holland
noch einen doppelpack 60 dortmund das 58
store im 63 bundesliga-spiel für
hollands oder in einem wort stark den
desolaten wölfen gelegt noch
ergebniskosmetik baku mit den
ehrentreffer dortmund glänzt und gewinnt
6 2 1 wolfsburg dagegen die erkenntnis
dass der klassenerhalt noch lange nicht
sicher ist
bayern zu gast auf der bielefelder alm
nach dem aus in der champions league der
tabellenführer von beginn an bissig
davis richtung lewandowski los und
schneller 10 bayern eigentor bielefeld
los um mit der brust ins eigene tor der
treffer wird überprüft und zählt die
nächste schlechte nachricht für die
arminia kunst wird im luftzweikampf von
ihren zugetroffen der bielefelder wird
lang behandelt muss verletzt raus und
wird zur weiteren untersuchung ins
krankenhaus gebracht
die münchner nur selten spielerische
überzeugen kimmig aufgabe 2 0 in der
nachspielzeit der ersten hälfte ambris
zwölftes saisontor wird auf abseits
überprüft und zählt am ende auch wenn
das bielefelds coach kramer wohl nicht
wahrhaben will
der rekordmeister insgesamt überlegen
lewandowski kurz vor schluss als
vorbereiter der eingewechselte musial
als vollstrecker zum 13 0 endstand
bielefeld rutscht nach der niederlage in
der tabelle ab die bayern können am
kommenden spieltag zu hause gegen den
erz rivalen aus dortmund die
meisterschaft vorzeitig klar machen
leverkusen und leipzig im direkten duell
um platz drei cds co steht nach dem
erfolg in der europa league komplett um
und bringt sieben neue leverkusen mit
einem neuen system hilft eine
dreierkette vorne mit chic und die als
doppelspitze nach einem verhaltenen
ersten durchgang die entscheidung in der
zweiten hälfte der eingewechselte im
kosovo 210 aber gleichzeitig der
endstand die sachsen vereinen leverkusen
den fünften auswärtssieg in serie und
sind neuer tabellendritter
[Applaus]
streiks freiburger sind weiter dicht
dran an den champions-league-plätzen der
sportclub zeit gegen den vfl bochum über
das gesamte spiel eine überzeugende
leistung und gäblers zweiten
saisontreffer nach fünf minuten in
führung in der 16 minute erhöhte auf 2 0
für die freiburger in der zweiten hälfte
ist es erneuter ungar der zum 13 0 für
die breisgauer per kopf trifft der vfl
bochum völlig von der rolle ist dafür
die das schlägt nach einer brutalen
grätsche gegen schott zu recht vom platz
wie auch kurz darauf sein trainer thomas
reis wegen einer abfälligen geste in
richtung des schiedsrichters die geste
so reiß hätte staffel liedes und dessen
foul gegolten so oder so aussieht als
erster bundesliga-trainer eine glatte
rote karte am ende gewinnt freiburg mit
3 zu 0 gegen bochum im breisgau darf
weiter von der königsklasse geträumt
werden
gladbach geht mit breiter brust ins
rheinische duell mit dem fc die fohlen
uns erhöhter zuletzt erstmals in der
liga viermal ungeschlagen jedoch sind es
die kölner die im derby jubeln modell
ist mit dem 1 0 in der fünften minute
der erste schuss der partie ist gleich
drehen der starke kainz erhöht auf 2 0
für die geißböcke die das derby über
weite strecken dominiert
nach einer guten halben stunde markiert
in lüttich das 13 0 für den ersten fc
köln in einem prestigeträchtigen
spielzeit gladbach insgesamt zu wenig
bolus tor kurz vor schluss kommt zu spät
1 zu 3 heißt es am ende aus sicht der
borussia köln triumphiert und gewinnt
seit über 30 jahren zum ersten mal beide
duelle gegen gladbach in einer saison
den berauschenden erfolg von eintracht
frankfurt in barcelona in der europa
league folgt ein ernüchterndes gastspiel
bei union berlin
die eintracht müde union von beginn an
wacher boni zum 1 0 für die köpenicker
die eisernen entscheiden das spiel
bereits in der ersten hälfte für sich
rühme zum 2 0-endstand
union feiert gegen frankfurt den dritten
sieg in serie und distanziert die sg in
der tabelle
es gibt gründe dass am ende zwischen
mainz und dem vfb keine zu gefallen auf
der einen seite passt center beim
rauslaufen stuttgart zürich überhastet
am leeren tor vorbei
auf der anderen seite steht dem mainzer
chor bei seinem kopfballversuch der
pfosten im weg vw keeper müller noch vor
der linie das sind die gründe für eine
nullnummer in mainz matratze stuttgarter
weiter mittendrin im abstiegskampf
abstiegsangst auch bei augsburg und
härter ein thema die berliner nach dem
derby debakel gegen union beim fca ohne
angstsymptome südsee oder mit der hacke
zum 1 0 für die berliner hohe kunst in
höchster tabellarischer notes ein
umkämpftes spiel gewinnt am ende die
härter knapp aber verdient augsburg
weiter mittendrin im abstiegskampf drei
wichtige punkte für die hauptstädter und
trainer magath der in seiner gesamten
karriere weder als spieler noch als
trainer abgestiegen ist felix der
glückliche
wir werden am wochenende nicht absteigen
so für trainer stefan leitl vollmundig
vor dem spiel in hoffenheim
in einer chancenarmen partie dramatisch
in der ersten hälfte die tsg führung auf
dem fuß und zieht die beste gelegenheit
für das kleeblatt julien green in der
zweiten hälfte doch baumann pariert
stark nur zu 0 zwischen hoffmann und
führt ein dämpfer für die kraichgauer
europa league ambitionen und wird ist in
der tat auch noch nicht rechnerisch
abgestiegen die ergebnisse des 30
spieltags im überblick dortmund mit
einer gala gegen wolfsburg bayern
gewinnt in bielefeld hertha feiert einen
wichtigen sieg in augsburg auf freiburg
und union mit drei punkten in der
tabelle bayern weiter neun punkte vor
dem bvb die münchner können am 31
spieltag im spitzenspiel gegen dortmund
die meisterschaft klarmachen union neuer
sechster am tabellenende
stuttgart auf dem relegationsplatz vor
bielefeld und führt
[Musik]